Tennyson why did you come to Los Angeles
to to make my mark in the entertainment
industry I had some my plans were
different than they are today and a lot
more naive and a lot less well informed
but they are I think far more glorious
as well as far more realistic so it's
been a it's been an ongoing evolution so
over time being in LA did you have a
clear picture of what it is that you
want to do and how you wanted to reach
that goal yeah absolutely absolutely and
it just working on film sets working
with people I respect working with
various different finance teams on
motion pictures writing a lot of
screenplays and through practice just
finding out what I like about film
myself making productions like the star
my record which i think is my first real
creative success all it is kind of help
a no continue but that's life we grow
there was an interesting article on
yahoo sometimes every yahoo articles and
it was ten reasons why people fail and
it was fascinating because I said you
know sometimes people don't have a broad
or their ideas too broad yes I want to
be a millionaire but they don't pinpoint
how I guess I want to be in the motion
picture industry I don't pinpoint how or
they're afraid of success rate of how
people may treat them differently if
they do succeed friends and family may
go little the opposite way ah so do you
think over time being here you've honed
in very specific ideas because I think
to I was the same way when I came here
we all have yeah we want to be here in
this industry but it's not clear how so
you say through practice for being here
so well you know what i would say i had
a lot of specific ideas when i got here
and i started implementing those plans
right away they were not the right plans
for me but by doing them i found that
out so it's it's been more of a changing
of the train tracks you know I I was
doing a lot more a tabletop role-playing
and gaming kind of stuff thinking I was
going to build much more of a multi
media empire and I've discovered that
film is in fact where I'm most happy and
most comfortable and i still have
designs along those lines but I'm
approach them in a much different way
now so so storytelling as a whole my
approach to storytelling and how I tell
those stories has evolved dramatically
you know and you can look back it's all
out there I've got tape I've got real
playing games on the internet right now
that I've written that are cool and our
probably content i'll even develop later
on you know and people play them we have
sold copies are people all around the
world australia that's excellent i'm
grateful and it's incredible you know
when the process of doing that has
taught me that it really is about
working with the actors and working with
the production team which is what i love
about real playing anyway you know so
your advice to a younger Tennyson you're
still very young is that let's say 10
years ago you could have written a you
know time travel send the younger
tenants in a lot about coming to LA what
would that letter beat I don't really
have any regrets um
uh it would be most about personal
choices just making it a little easier
for myself you know what I mean I'd love
to I'd love to have my social life a
little more good than it is I don't time
management time management relaxation I
would love to teach young Tennyson how
to relax even right now I'm a little you
know I've got the crazy eye that's
interesting that you say because I think
do you think that there is a way to
really try to come up in any business
whether it's auto sales or running
script and have a personal life in the
first first few years that's possible I
think what's 50 years ago I don't know
maybe we're too specialized and there's
too much work now I don't know um I
would have loved to have put more of a
focus on it you know I think probably
had I had more of a personal it could
have gotten just as much writing done
probably probably but but um you know
how it is i think i think we're all
reaching that age where we start to
realize that if we don't start managing
our health a little bit more creatively
a little more intelligently and a little
more calmly we're gonna be suffering the
consequences i know that's true for a
lot of filmmakers I know in my same
position you know over extension is a
big big big challenge in New Hollywood
and learning getting a leg up on
mastering that problem I think would've
been really good for me which I did not
do acknowledge that one
you